all right hello everyone uh welcome to
another wolfram language design review
part of our language completeness and
consistency series
all right first up we seem to have a
very
uh old chestnut
break is broken
yes
right so so
break is dynamically scoped right so
sort of on the plus side
that means you can write a function
that returns a break and then you can
use that and then
that's horrifying
right
so
right on the minus side well you can
write a function that returns a break
that
right so you know if you if you
pass in a function to another function
that might
sort of
expose the internal details of that
function so here's a resource function
that's implemented using a do loop and
so this break
in the second input
rather than breaking the do loop it's
per you know the do loop you see it's
breaking the do loop inside of the
resource function okay let's let's zoom
out it should do it it's named break
it's breaking code
let's let's zoom out for a moment okay
okay so right now we have constructs
like break continue return
okay
and
you know one of the questions and i mean
okay
we also have user assistance
capabilities so for example
return
could have the property that if you
mouse over it it indicates it selects
the you know the thing which it is going
to return from that would at least give
you some fighting chance of knowing what
the hell the return was going to do
that's a particular type of usage though
where we're mostly concerned i think
with programmatic usage
no no i i what do you mean by
programmatic usage
people are using these in programs where
they they are not visually inspecting
code or with a mouse or anything like
that no no i understand that i
understand it but i'm saying when you
write the code initially
you know it's a question of what is this
return going to do
well
of the dynamic scoping that you can't
tell just by reading the code like in
this example here if you don't know
what's inside table while you have no
way of knowing whether the break is
going to
where it's going to trigger
right that's horrifying well it's
you know
where i don't understand what this is
hold on hold on hold on what is this
even doing here you mean table while has
a break inside it no table while has a
do loop inside of it um
and so
the first input works fine
but on the second input where the user
has put in the break
rather than that break breaking the do
loop that they wrote it breaks an
internal do loop oh my god that's so
horrifying right which is why the third
and fourth outputs are the same rather
than
you know it's just returning the first
three outputs
right well first point is we can't
change this function as such
it's been there for 35 years we cannot
change it
however
okay so the point here is that this
break
goes into the hidden underworld
basically it breaks in the underworld
um
okay
but it would be useful to have something
which breaks the do you are currently
writing
a lexical break basically right right
so so
it's an error
if it doesn't appear in a do loop
exactly
i also wonder if it's useful to have
um
labeled breaks and or break this
particular function
break you know so so return has an
undocumented second argument
that says you know not break the module
or the block don't break or sorry don't
return from
you know something inner
sure but even if we do that you know
this double do
yeah situation will fool it exactly
which is which is why i really don't
like the idea of actually making use of
label but i'm wondering if that would
actually be useful
no it said no no
no
there are other ways to have control
flow you know i have not wanted a go-to
and a label
in decades i i don't think i've wanted
one in 35 years that that is how you
would get around this issue if you
really wanted to get around this issue
which issue i don't even know
where you break from instead of using
break you just go to and label oh no no
but i didn't mean to use go to what i
mean what i mean is other languages have
the ability to label the loop
so that you can break an outer loop from
within an inner loop
yeah
that i see your point
okay but hold on let me just understand
go to and label okay
i mean i've i've not needed that
functionality i've not wanted that
functionality because
the
so maybe we just don't okay but so the
issue that we have here
and by the way tags you know throw is a
great example is a good example of a bad
example of tagging
i don't think the tags and throw were a
big success
i mean they're useful for our internal
implementation but i think they're
pretty hard to understand and they're
pretty dangerous because it's like oh
you know some other piece of code
happens to have that same tag in the
underworld again
well that that's
simple really bad
luck
what do you mean it's bad luck i mean
should not be part of the programming
calculation well no but the tag if you i
mean we don't make this super clear but
the right way to use the tag in like
internal code is to define some symbol
in some weird private context and use
that as your tag
and even a unique of that yeah yeah
right yeah
right but that's pretty horrifying i
mean you know that's a that's a uuid
story which is perhaps the way that in
modern times that's no more horrifying
than the pattern matcher matches on
symbols that you might write declare in
some you know package or context or give
it a name it's no more horrifying than
that i mean that's kind of fun because
it's a completely hidden state it's
completely hidden what's going on you do
a throw inside internal inside inside
food food code so to speak that's being
fed to another piece of code the piece
of code that's being fed to you don't
see inside the animal it's being fed to
see what i'm saying but somehow that
animal
somehow chokes
on the food you gave it
right although if although if that
function happened to define a value for
variable and global
then you would have the same
bad you know
fair enough that point yeah i mean if
you have a but that's a visible side
effect whereas
catching
yeah
i agree
but i think it's more of the great
manner of degree than a matter of kind
you're making the argument against
exceptions which is
yes
no i'm not particularly making the
argument no no i'm not i'm making the
argument the following argument
in the case of a global variable you
know in in a function you know you're
declaring something that has a global
side effect
okay in the case of a catch where you
say
throw foo catch foo inside your function
right
you don't know that foo wasn't localized
and i mean the truth is the way you
should do it you should do it as module
foo
outside of the throw catch would that
work that would work so long as the
throw catch is lexically in the code but
if the throw catch it would work because
the flu variable gets uniquified
no i know but it would only work if the
throw catch were both lexically visible
inside the scope of the module but i
don't see how that's different from just
using a foo variable it's just some
weird thing from an internet
i agree it isn't much different except
that that module has a has a semi
requirement to generate something unique
okay let's go back to this problem okay
so this problem is
that right now
you don't know
that break is going to that this
function is going to choke on the break
now if we were to have
a
i mean
what does break break out of let's let's
ask that basic question first do while
for
maybe scan i'm not sure
you know i would say that a recovery
from this
would be to have a thing called break do
break while break four
is that completely crazy well it just
won't help if there's you know
double usage or more of no i would say
and have those be lexical
why don't we just have break lexical
right because the word lexical is
extremely weird
why instead of having three breaks why
not just have one
well but breaking okay first question is
okay that's fine what about continue
it continues fine as well what does it
do
it's it's the same three it's the same
set of functions
it'll it'll have the same issue as break
so okay so what what continuous doing
is going to the nearest and closing loop
operative now the operation
correct yes and and something like it's
only the pure side effect once so a
table doesn't have a meaningful continue
but a table could have a meaningful
break
because you have to know what what would
the table return you know an unfinished
a list that that doesn't isn't as long
as you thought it was going to be no i
think that's insane
i do not like that either
doesn't doesn't throw what does throw do
in that case just because it just
it's everything right you can't
interpose the catch so
you you won't you won't have your table
it could never happen
that the code's either you know executed
or not
yeah fair point if you throw out you
know from inside a table to outside you
lose your table
yeah okay so are there any other
functions in modern times
because this was from ancient times
right this is a version one function
my god it was updated
there's some i mean this relates a
little bit too i remember around the you
know when we were talking about enclosed
and confirmed stuff one of the things
that we did talk a little bit about
was having like a lexical throw
um and like a lexical catch or something
like that i don't know what their names
would be but it seems slightly relevant
which is which would only
operate within the visible code
yeah so i mean what it would sort of i
mean it's a little bit niche
but i mean basically what it would let
you do is is right now if you're using
thrown catch right if you're using throw
and catch and you're throwing you know
across
many you know functions and so on then
there's there's nothing you can do about
that if however you're using throw and
catch within one function like you know
lexically together
um i mean right now
there are cases where you still have to
use a tag because uh maybe you're
there's some hold hold all stuff going
on
um but but basically this would mean
that
you know you can safely use them
together even if there is hold all stuff
going on there won't be a problem but i
think that's an interesting thing so i
mean this is what return this this is
kind of what return is it's like
returning from the enclosing function
right although you can't control as much
where the like like you might want to
throw and catch you know i don't know
you're mapping over something and in
each loop you do have some throw and
catch inside you know the return only
goes to only assumes that you know the
catch is around the whole function
right
also return is is a weird you know and
kind of saying the local throw
lexical local catch that encloses it
right and it's an error if there isn't a
local catch it's an errol yes
same semantics as in close and confirm
and they have to be inside the same
function
not necessarily i mean they just have to
be lexically you know the local sorry
they have to be lexically related no
sorry excuse me they have to be
lexically right this this isn't crazy
so sorry i i
i'm saying this isn't crazy yeah i agree
so so
actually i was going to borrow from our
undocumented return maybe instead of
one new function or three new functions
we have break of due break of
return
uh break of uh
while and break of
four
that uh you know those have to be lex
lexical
i think it's a little bit crazy if if
the you know break open closes dynamic
but break of due is lexical i feel like
that could be pretty confusing
although
although
and enclose and confirm have the same
that's that's true i guess yeah
well
well
it's where you give them a tag right i
think if you give them a tag i mean it's
basically saying if you give me the
tools to be dynamic i'll be dynamic or
like safely dynamic i'll be dynamic as
opposed to just if you give me a
function name
which has nothing to do with whether
it's dynamic or lexical then it will
it'll become lexical
yeah although in this case it doesn't
know if it was lexical here
with with a pure break
it's a little less clear what the thing
would actually break to so to speak
um i mean it's already unclear what the
break is gonna break to
yo i know
i have to say i
i mean what would happen okay let's
imagine we have a local break local
continue
local throw local catch
is local the term for lexical
yeah i i think the
i think the throw and catcher a
different you know pot of fish from the
break and continue
why
because this would mean
i mean it's kind of also solving a
different problem i mean because like
the the thing with the throne catch is
just that there are a couple of fairly
niche cases where thrown catches is sort
of unsafe and so you have to use tags
and stuff and it's a pain i mean
alternatively i mean the problem with
with you know break continue et cetera
is more just these are kind of archaic
and
and weird functions the question is is
there a modernization of these that is
meaningful so hold on let me just try
something here because i don't even know
what this does okay so if i do this
otherwise honestly
my intention will be that the value of
break continue etc is really in
translating low-level code i mean if you
if you're reading some pseudo code and
it's written with for loops and while
loops and breaks and stuff like that
it's useful to be able to just kind of
translate that what the hell did this
just do
so break
dynamically on evaluation
i see causes that to happen
right right yeah i mean that's what it
does
i mean that did the right thing there
didn't it yeah i think so so i mean but
but on the other hand if i were to say
right then of course it broke before
it got squared right because power is
not called anything
but if it got squared who cares
to try running this because it'll run
the whole thing yeah yeah yeah i think
so
now what happens if i if i actually echo
the break
i don't think you'll see anything
yeah okay fine all right what is the
modern what it was one really trying to
achieve with breaking is there a more
modern version of it you're basically
trying i mean there are certain
i mean i agree that in the you know
oftentimes it's because people are are
coming from c or fortran but
you know there are matrix algorithms for
example right where you're starting in
the upper left corner where i don't know
how you write them without
you know loops right you end up with you
end up with a otherwise you end up with
some kind of nest while type construct
yeah why don't anything you wrote with
great i mean he's always replaceable
with a conditional
break
is better it's better to have
you know not to have to use the dreaded
for loop and manipulate one of the
indices which is kind of what you could
do with break though you can always
implement break by with a while loop and
have a condition you know while
you know flag and then set the flag in
in the break so look i mean it's
difficult yes you can but
you may want to break into in the middle
of it based on some condition that's
just
going to make it harder it's not it's
not unuseful right yeah there you go
that's that's not what you should be
useful no i don't argue that tom i i
think it's useful but
not sufficiently general to cover all
cases one uses it now
sorry wait a minute the enough
resolution didn't work for me what's the
this were you guys talking about this
thing here are you talking about
something exactly actually i was saying
the message was good
so not you you want to
what do you want to see here
i want to see the list um
you know on a short list yeah shortened
list
well then you would have nothing instead
of
you know
well you just wouldn't have that list
there or you would have possibly you
returned nothing no but you would have
if i greater than three
nothing otherwise i cubed
right well it would have to be
throw nothing to the you know outer part
of the table or something like that but
yeah
i mean i mean if you throw nothing the
table will just terminate no not throw
nothing
make the result of the if statement
nothing
i know t-h-i-n-g oh yeah yeah right
right right right then then that won't
work though it'll still go on to that no
no no no get rid of the put the i-cubed
in the
put the iq out right right
right yeah and you're gonna you can
express this
idea now
that's that seems a more satisfactory by
the way we should probably have a a link
from break to nothing
yeah
cool in the documentation well well but
none of the functions that break works
with right now return things where it's
anything like nothing
yeah it's like twice removed
okay if not thrice
okay all right fine
um
okay this is a perfectly reasonable way
to do this what's that go ahead there's
an open suggestion that we implement
something along the lines of a loop
protect
which would protect that inner loop in
the example each i first showed i think
from break or continue oh i think this
is so obscure
yeah that's that's that's in the
category of you know ship is sinking and
you pump more water out yeah yeah sorry
i i will disagree i think it's in the
category of
i have this function that's going to
work on other people's code and i don't
know what their code will do
right right and the problem
happens if we have the lexical break
then we we've solved that problem
maybe well no because people can still
have the dynamic break but i mean i
think that the more general problem is
that there are i mean we have a
proliferation of these you know abort
protect and and stuff like that that
there's i mean there's like if you want
to be able to run someone's code in your
code and be like this is 100 totally
bulletproof it won't break anything
i i don't even know you probably need
you know 15
be rappers but in this case you only
need loop protect around loops
okay but hold on
being able to safely run somebody's code
is a sandboxing problem and we're
currently in the process of making
better sandboxes this this will still be
an issue stephen
look it depends on how sandbox the samba
i mean
i think i i think steven steven i think
you're confusing what what is meant by
safe here i mean sand boxing solves the
problem of you know i don't want bad
side effects from this
you know
danny and christopher are talking about
you know i'm taking this input function
and i still want it to
evaluate in the way that both i and the
user intend
and you know that my implementation
details don't affect the user's
implementation details yeah that's
exactly right yeah i mean this is like
like like like for example to use one
other example unevaluated right if you
feed unevaluated to most functions it
breaks them in some bizarre and way
that's totally communication dependent
and and it's like there's no you know
they're they're
they're like probably
15 different kinds of things like
unevaluated that can just unexpectedly
break your code if someone gives it to
correct
and so i think you know maybe we could
add more to protect against these other
cases but i kind of don't know how any
of these are useful because i don't know
when i'd use any of them okay so
basically the basic point is there are
things you can feed
functions black box functions that are
poisonous to the black box functions in
unexpected ways
that's a true statement
right
and
understanding how to make something that
is not poisonous
that could never be poisonous i mean
the question is if the eating function
is knows it's going to be fed something
how can it guarantee it's not poisonous
i mean it could it could guarantee it
for example by turning it into an
abstract syntax tree then it's deeply
inert
well you don't necessarily want to be a
nerd you might want to run it
yeah i know so that's the problem of
sandboxes
you know
if you sandbox completely it's it's like
the problem of you know well but you're
not trying to sandbox completely like
for example you know there's a bug
because if you take confirm and you put
an unevaluated into its nth argument i
don't even know which one then it it
breaks a little bit or it runs the thing
twice
right and it's like
you know
that that nth argument you know maybe
it's it still needs to run it still
needs to have side effects in the code
outside of the confirm
etc but it's just
it's just that there's a lot of kind of
weird cases like that that you can get
yourselves into i understand okay let's
come back let's let's return to these
things okay so first point is local
throw local catch
i don't know that's lexical is there a
better name than local i mean another
possibility is to have throw of local
you know like other charts
not a chance we've got to have a
different
construct i think
i don't know what people are anything
from the confirming clothes
world that could help if you're looking
for names
right
i
catching
think so because they're all just
they all just are implicitly lexical
yeah but could you have any one
enclosed throw and catch and close or
something i don't know
i mean one fairly crazy thing i i don't
tom i don't know if this is what you
were suggesting but you could have the
tag be something special
yeah and it's also probably going to be
i mean
one of the
it sort of also defeats the point
because the advantage of this is that it
basically lets you not use a tag in a
few instances yeah you see this would be
a nice way of bailing out of a scan or a
map or a phone or something
right
look i think we should consider local
throw local catch okay
um
with the other revamping of handle and
raise and things like that i mean they
should be more modernized surely
well i think these are these are a
little different i mean the stuff if
you're talking about the error handling
stuff i feel like
that's i mean right now throw and catch
are one of the main exception mechanisms
i think the rays and handler whatever i
don't even remember what they're called
those would be kind of a you know a new
exception mechanism and
these new throne catches would be sort
of relegated to the other use of thrown
catch which is just kind of
small-scale control flow
[Music]
but that that's correct i believe it
might still be useful
um
a little bit off scope for for the
question at hand
although it might be useful in its own
right okay so look i think it's useful
in its own right and i think we should
look at implementing this but let's talk
about break
let's talk about break because i agree
that we need a version of break that
just breaks out of the lexical
you know
the lexical do that it is
so um so what what's what's the problem
we're solving though is the problem
we're solving that that people people
are afraid that they're going to write
code with a do in it and that it's going
to be unsafe or are we fixing the
problem that people will put break into
a piece of code and it will break if you
know what i mean like like because the
point is is that
you know
if for example we add another function
called you know
better break
um and then maybe we deprecate the old
break i mean is that kind of enough like
is that what we're trying to do
yeah i think so i mean what what i think
we should be doing is let's say we have
local break
and local continue
and
all they do
is just they do the lexical version
of breaking out of the lexically
enclosing
do while four
that sounds fine
and that way
you know
i think we should look at doing that
local break local continue local throw
local catch why don't we have local
return then that does the same thing
with functions what's it going to return
out of
the enclosing function doesn't return
already do that
well it has all sorts of weird
astonishingly weird extra functionality
to argument form tom's correct but
in every sense the true argument form
can tell what function to break out of
but it's still not lexical no no no we
should have a lexical thing it's very
obvious what the enclosing function is
for what is per turn for return
wait it goes out to the place where it
hits a down value is that correct
it would return from like the nearest
set delayed or function
with a camera or
because i mean if you map over something
and you return into math
i'm not gonna know maybe maybe
that's why you would use local throne
local catch
this doesn't mean this is why i'm
skeptical of returning generals because
basically
you can basically always get the
behavior of return with throwing cash
and it's just more explicit what's going
on
well you can you can get the behavior of
two argument uh return with throw and
catch i don't think you can get
the the our behavior of one and three
zero one argument
obviously no i i think what he meant
because what you know discussion what
the implementation of return should be
sorry we we just hold on
tom
you say that but you made a comment
about function like the function it says
function look at the page it says
function
we have two notions of function we have
lambda functions anonymous functions and
we have name functions yeah okay but
what is this
what what what are we even discussing
okay in this case it could be a module
no no no no
yes right now
yeah in the current version who knows it
will help the return through this
tuesday it does and if it's wednesday it
doesn't wait a second wait a second
second if hash is greater than three
return
he's testing the the
no it just does the obvious thing it
doesn't return from that function
what the heck
i'm not sure that is the obvious thing
hold on hold on let's do this i think
that's close to correct
well i i think the thing is right a lot
of languages when you have sort of an
anonymous function it's just like a
normal function in the sense that
returning from the anonymous function
you know calling returning the analysis
function returns from it but i think
there may be two differences one is that
uh in a lot of those languages
their syntax for defining an anonymous
function is very similar to their syntax
for defining a named function and
they're kind of more similar and so it
makes sense that return has the same
behavior between them we don't really
have very similar syntax the other thing
would just be
that
i mean we do have really a lot of kind
of little anonymous functions everywhere
um that
that most other languages don't have
right look
this seems very bizarre and arguably
wrong and certainly not documented
it's returning from the function but not
the map
i know return did nothing return to
nothing right
no no no but look it it didn't do
nothing
semicolon
didn't do nothing it didn't do nothing
look why didn't it just follow on in the
compound expression and give
squares right it actually did
right but something very bizarre why do
i return return of food
because
right because that's what return does
when it's not inside of anything right
so if you just evaluated return of foo
by itself in an input cell you'd get
trouble
but if it did actually return if it this
seems like it could be a bug i mean if
it did actually do some returning
behavior i mean you cannot i don't think
return is even
localized to a function i just sent you
an example if i where we have a return
inside a function and it leaks out of
the function and and
okay like i just sent you an example
where you have a function passed to a
function
function
i just sent it
yeah
and and if you have this if you call
that function in a loop then the one
with return breaks out of the loop and
the one without return doesn't
so i mean it's just
even though it's defined inside a
function so i don't know if you want to
share that or not
but it's always
even localized properly
this is a different issue i mean what
what is what's the what is going on with
that example with the return of foo i
mean i just don't understand
is it it seems like that would be a bug
i mean because it was this is what tom
said
no it's not he said it should return 149
foo fufu
correct
not return of food
correct is more bizarre yeah this comes
out to them
you're returning from the function
but what are you returning you're
returning the payload
yeah
okay but do you think this is a bug so
you believe this is a bug
i think it's endemic to our
implementation of return
yeah it's also something that would be
extremely hard to fix
it would probably break the world
because there's so much code that
depends on these weird vagaries
okay we're not you shouldn't be relying
on return being returned you shouldn't
be lying down in your code on return
being returned from a function that's
just i mean if you're relying on that
you've really done
what the language will happen i i agree
with you
i agree with you i mean not just years
ago i tried to change this
and the
the amount of damage it did was
horrifying okay so let's just review
what it is we're actually saying here
the
you're saying there is a notion of
returning up to a you know there's
return up to a colon equals
return
up to a set delayed or something set or
set delayed
actually it has to be a set delay
doesn't it no
why why does it have to be acceptable oh
because it would have evaluated
otherwise
yeah
right okay so that's notion number one
notion number two is return
uh inside a
function capital function
right
and
which i claim i mean clearly it's broken
here
i mean it's been broken for three
decades probably
now i mean i claim
that if you see return
i would expect it to just really go to
something well defined like the
this is horrifying if you happen to put
your return you thought it was going to
be a boom i'm returning up to the set
delayed
but you happen to have that return
inside a function function
it would shield it i bet i bet i've run
into this but you could you could have a
set delayed insider set delayed it's the
same thing i mean come on
wait a minute can you wait a minute wait
wait wait wait wait definitely can these
are very common it's much more common of
a pure function inside of a set delay
i think we should be
lowering the boundaries between set
delayed functions and lambda the only
difference should be one has a name and
the other doesn't we should break these
boundaries
there's a huge difference there's a huge
difference you know our set delayed type
functions are transformation rules
right now functions
not a detail it's not a detail because
right now our function function is an
omnivore
right you've you've changed that a bit
with types
we've never had hold on we've never it's
not a detail at all we've never had a
mechanism to have a function function
look that that eats where the thing it
eats i mean we've talked about having
such a mechanism where if you feed it
four or five
where we give some syntax here like for
example
you know it's called replace by the way
if you want a thing for
an anonymous replacement rules it's like
a terrible weakness that we could
certainly could support syntax like that
it would be very useful actually
people put set delayed inside other set
delays to get this sort of behavior
there's no reasonable discussion there's
a separate discussion totally totally
agree with that hold on that's a
separate discussion we have looked at
this multiple times there are all kinds
of issues with it but we can certainly
look at it again of having the
possibility of wait wait wait having the
possibility of patterns inside functions
but let's let's review for a second
please the thing that we actually was
supposed to be reviewing which is return
okay
and to me it seems like there is a
well-defined notion of return which is
return to the nearest and closing set
delayed
which would be the analog of local break
local continue
if somehow
i'm still a little bit confused whether
the code you're running always has
uh
yeah i mean
would there be any sense in having
some differently named return that
definitively just goes to the nearest
and closing
you know set delayed
maybe yeah
didn't we know by the way whether our
stream failed
[Music]
right i mean i
i i i kind of agree with fun with tom
that if we have this new
construct that it would make sense to to
put function and
you know set the light on an equal
footing i mean right i i'm not sure i
agree with that but but look the basic
point here is
okay right now
okay the first thing we were dealing
with was break and continue i think
we've got this concept of local throw
local catch local break local continue
so at least we've we've got a solution
to that a lexical version of that right
now the question is is there any change
we want to make to return
right i think in the past i mean right
this is certainly not the first time
we've discussed this although it's the
first time in a while i think the name
we sort of came up with in the previous
iteration is that the new version of
return would be returned from
but that seems a little weird if we're
very good yeah
well you'd say what return from of foo
or foo is my
function with down values
yeah
yeah
maybe it could be called like function
return but if we call it function return
then then what does it do with pure
functions right yeah all right let's
have that on a separate agenda yeah fine
okay so we've got local cat local throw
local catch local break local continue
let's let's try and implement those
aren't the names though right or those
aren't the final names necessarily not
necessarily if we can come up with
better names
okay
um
okay let's have a quick look at um uh
we've got several important things here
and we're going to run out of time i
want to look at supplied just from well
do you guys have good things to say
about this have you really been working
on this one manipulating health
expressions
um no because we were
yeah we uh
um well i think there was a little bit
of a breakdown in in project management
but also
we we had sort of just started on sort
of the next thing about
uh
you know
these other things when
we haven't really got anywhere let's
look at let's look at supply
um
right so the big thing here is right is
this more comprehensive list of
functions where we might want them
um
and they're sort of uh
you know two sets the ones where
wouldn't make sense to have both
contextual variables and supplied
and the ones which where it only makes
sense to have contextual variables
because supply really wants to
surround the function
right
well it could supply surround a rule as
well in the replace family
we decided against that why
what do those things bind to
say that again we'll explain that again
so i mean in the case of a function a
pure function what we would be doing is
we'd be saying supplied
of um right like list
index comma
uh you know
i think this is one of the original
reasons we started talking about
contextual variables is that it would be
some i didn't know that was the term we
were using is that you can base you
could basically just bind them to
you know
they can just be sort of always bound
things that you can use in the right
hand side of the well
well well no yeah right the idea was
this could be
pound one and pound two now right
no no that's what supplied does but
right yes that's what i'm saying yeah i
i'm ta i'm i'm i'm talking about
input stephen
that just stephen just typed in right
that pounded text plus bound data should
be pound one plus bound two
so the point is if you had a rule right
this is an example right you know you
have some some payload and then you have
a you know your replacement rule is
something like you know displaying ghost
goes to index plus
x
or dollar dollar index plus b
right if you try to write that as supply
that that that wouldn't make any sense
because there would be
nothing to hold the string index
i see what you're saying no no no way to
refer to the string index right right
now here why isn't this building an
association of these things i mean it
seems to me the code would be much
easier to read mostly if that builds an
association in this case
um
say this
right well the idea was that we
could
um
and
maybe that was going to be
one argument
i think we maybe talked about that being
a one arguments applied right but the
idea was you could use applied right you
wouldn't have to rewrite your function
each time you
changed what
right if if that was going to be you
know arctan to argument arctan right you
could just do
arctan there instead of arctan of
pounded and x comma pound data which
would be a really stupid function but
you get the point
i'm not sure i do i mean this this what
we said is that supplied would lexically
figure out
in a case like this
what things it has to supply
based on the names of these variables
right then we went from that to this
idea of just having variables that hang
out there
right
but they're right the the the right the
and the supplied with the name strings
the two arguments implied is precisely
so that you can take you know
predefine the down value based functions
and feed them in
and adapt what are the inputs
based on
the context that you're feeding that
predefined function
into okay
go ahead
yeah
well sorry i was just gonna ask one
other quick thing which is with the
contextual variable stuff was the idea
that those would be lexically scoped
uh i think probably not gotten that far
i think i think we decided that those
definitely had to be
lexically scoped yeah i think they have
to be because
if they
don't appear they don't get bound that's
correct exactly yes but there are lots
of things that could be astonishingly
expensive to do this in remap you know
right but so so where are we at with the
idea of dollar dollar index dollar oil
data
so we
consider so as it says i mean
implementationally
um i don't think right we had that
prototype
no four dollars for dollar dollar index
i don't think we've had any sort of
implementation and last time we
considered replacing that with you know
that different full form
yes
i like that idea i think that the
you know
well
in fact if we were going to do that
it would make more sense to have some
kind of
other
prefix form here
that prince i mean i don't know what we
have available but um
um
we don't have a lot available anymore
um
i'm looking at my keyboard and trying to
see what might be available as a as a
prefix form
that's always scary you know one of the
problems like at the summer school we've
had this where you know we'll use some
weird symbol like a tilde or something
with international keyboards they don't
have that symbol
yes
the worst swedish keyboards where to
type a square bracket i think you need
to do like option shift
alt gr
yeah
right um
[Music]
i mean who knows what what the um you
know let's imagine you know x time
question mark x let's say whatever it is
um
that
is a syntax
that means contextual variable
i mean
what's i mean is this does this make
semantic sense to have something like
this that is a lexical object
that appears
in a pure function
in a way that is to be supplied by the
pure function
i mean are these well defined do we do
we know what the variables are for each
one of these functions
like for example let's let's take the
example of nest graph
okay let's say we have one of the
variables means
the iteration number for nest list
that's very well defined
for nest graph that's much less well
defined
so i mean i think though that they don't
necessarily like it will be nice if we
can use the same names of these
variables between lots of functions but
i think it's not necessary right each
function map will still have its own
documented table of here are the
contextual variables i supply a nest
list or have its own list and they might
happen to
you know align nice ways right which is
part of why i you know we tried to group
them this way i mean these are things
you know sort of each bullet point are
things that we think are likely to
have the same or mostly the same
contextual okay so i've got another
point that's similar to this okay things
like you know between mesh functions
vertex shape functions yep that's on our
list uh on uh that's like the last three
or the
last and anti-penultimate bullet points
right region function is there and mesh
function is there
so hold on though but by the way i mean
so
there's one slightly weird thing that's
happening though which is it's this
contextual variable is slowly turning
into another version of lambda functions
with with named parameters just like
just like you know feeding an
association to an existing lambda
function because basically you'd imagine
that you know if we have proper support
for these we'll have some outer function
that lets you basically you know
give the you know you have some outer
function where you give it say a pure
function or some other piece of code and
it will uh you know and then you give it
a set of say replacement rules where you
tell it if you see a contextual variable
index
evaluate this function to find the index
or something like that
and you'd have to you know
you know it'll probably
like
this is extremely similar to function
application
so i don't know it's but once your
because it's lazy in evaluating the
arguments
um
[Music]
and i guess maybe at least in terms of
the internal implementation of things
like map you'd want it so it doesn't
have you'd love it if it didn't have to
scan the input function more than once
um
but look basically this is a this is a
footnote to a function it's it's it's
in addition to
being fed its main i don't know why
we're talking about food so much um you
know it's main argument right it's main
food this is some kind of uh you know
it's some kind of seasoning on the food
he says
you know
it um
it's some additional piece
that's coming in and being referenced
within the body of the function
by this contextualized variable thing
but i don't quite understand how it
okay
we've run out of time here um
we need to continue this this is i think
we should have a complete custom meeting
that's applied this is going to
definitely take a whole
session to go over this
makes sense
okay
and i just asked is the point of it to
gather information when you trans when
you when you traverse this these
specific flags yeah for example with map
okay
right now we have map and map indexed
right but we can imagine more general
forms of map indexed
right and also there's a whole bunch of
you know should we have a scan index too
like there's a whole bunch of functions
there's a whole combinatorial set
of these you know yeah and we ran into
this for tree map because tree map has
this you know do we need a tree map
indexed and so on
and i'm not a big fan yeah go ahead
sorry i just
i've got a couple of questions i'm just
trying to get a conceptual idea of it
but it doesn't change
the
the way that you iterate through it like
the pre-order
it just gathers the information of
whatever the iterator through that
object is doing for example yes
okay
i mean it could so for example
uh
right i mean in
yeah i mean the the term index versus
the term position index although we've
you know could mean just the top level
first level index position means the
whole
you know list that gets provided in map
indexed and so on
um
uh anyway i need to go but um uh till we
continue guys can we get a complete
meeting about supplied please
ok i'm going to disappear see you guys
later